when you pick a fight with Disney you
need to play to win and so far Governor
DeSantis has been outworked and
outmaneuvered by Disney
as far as I know Reedy Creek is still
exists they're still hosting trans
events at their park what is a trans
event exactly this indoctrination is
continuing and they're actually rubbing
it in the faces of American families you
know if you can't beat Donald Duck how
are you going to beat Donald Trump this
idea that you would love Trump but hate
DeSantis they're sort of two sides of
the same coin so a lot of this character
assassination of one in favor of the
other is quite contrived the reality is
that on issues and positions and culture
War and the whole thing to the extent
that they take positions on issues most
people who like one of these clowns
would like the other that's the reality